RACHEL: THE FDA AUTHORIZING
COVID’S VACCINE FOR EMERGENCY
USE CLEARING THE WAY FOR
MILLIONS OF DOSES TO BE ROLLED
OUT WITHIN DAYS.
>> I’M THRILLED TO REPORT THAT
THE FDA HAS AUTHORIZED THE
PFIZER VACCINE.
WE HAVE ALREADY BEGUN SHIPPING
THE VACCINE TO EVERY STATE AND
ZIP CODE IN THE COUNTRY.
THE FIRST VACCINE WILL BE
ADMINISTERED IN LESS THAN 24
HOURS.
THE PANDEMIC MAY HAVE BEGUN IN
CHINA BUT WE ARE ENDING IT RIGHT
HERE IN AMERICA.
RACHEL: HERE WITH NEW DETAILS
FOX NEWS MEDICAL CONTRIBUTOR
DR. NICOLE SAPHIER.
NICOLE, WELCOME.
TELL US ABOUT THE SPEED OF THIS
GOING OUT AND ALSO SOME PEOPLE
ARE CONCERNED THAT THE SPEED
MIGHT BE IMPACTING THE SAFETY.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT?
>> WELL, RACHEL, I DON’T THINK
MOST PEOPLE UNDERSTAND WHAT A
INCREDIBLE SCIENTIFIC FEAT THIS
HAS BEEN.
SO MULTILAYER VACCINE FOR
TECHNOLOGY FOR A DISEASE THAN
PRESENT LESS THAN A YEAR AND HAS
A 95% EFFICACY BUT THANKS TO
OPERATION WARP SPEED IT’S READY
TO BE DISTRIBUTED AND
ADMINISTERED WITHIN 24 TO 48
HOURS OF RECEIVING THAT FDA EUA.
THAT IS UNPRECEDENTED.
AND I UNDERSTAND WHY PEOPLE FEEL
THAT, YOU KNOW, THEY DON’T LIKE
THE TERM WARP SPEED.
THEY FEEL LIKE MAYBE SAFETY
CORNERS ARE BEING CUT.
THAT IS NOT THE CASE.
THE BIG THING HERE, THE
SCIENTIFIC DISCOVERY PROCESS HAS
HE NOT BEEN TAINTED WHATSOEVER.
WHAT HAPPENED WAS THROUGH
OPERATION WARP SPEED THEY WERE
MANUFACTURING THE VACCINE IN
PARALLEL WHILE THEY WERE STILL
STUDYING IT.
THAT USUALLY DOESN’T HAPPEN
BECAUSE THERE IS A CHANCE THAT
THE VACCINE WON’T BE SUCCESSFUL.
BUT BECAUSE OPERATION WARP SPEED
PUT MONEY INTO THE
MANUFACTURING, HOPING THAT IT
WOULD BE SUCCESSFUL, THAT IS WHY
WE HAVE THE VACCINE RIGHT NOW.
IT IS NOT CUTTING SAFETY CORNERS
WHATSOEVER.
RACHEL: NOW, THAT SAID, THERE
ARE SOME PEOPLE IN THE -- MAINLY
PREGNANT WOMEN THAT THEY ARE
SAYING SHOULD NOT RECEIVE THIS
VACCINE.
WHY?
>>
>> WELL, RIGHTFULLY SO IN
CLINICAL TRIALS THERE ARE
CERTAIN PEOPLE EXCLUDED STUDYING
MEDICATIONS.
PREGNANT PEOPLE, YOUNG IT THOSE
WILL -- WHEN YOU ARE STUDYING
SOMETHING NEW.
BECAUSE WE DON’T HAVE DATA ON
THEM WE CAN’T NECESSARILY
RECOMMEND THAT THEY TAKE IT.
IT’S POSSIBLE THAT IT WOULD BE
COMPLETELY SAFE IN THEM WE CAN’T
PROVE IT.
BECAUSE WE CAN’T PROVE IT, WE
HAVE TO HOLD OFF ON RECOMMENDING
IT.
THERE ARE STUDIES THAT ARE GOING
TO BE STARTED IN EARLY 2021 FOR
PREGNANT PEOPLE AND FOR OTHERS;
HOWEVER, WE DON’T HAVE THE DATA
QUITE YET.
WHICH, FOR THOSE WOMEN WHO ARE
PREGNANT OR PLANNING TO BECOME
PREGNANT, WE UNDERSTAND BECAUSE
COVID-19 CAN BE SCARY FOR THEM
IT.
IS SHOWING TO HAVE SOME NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES THE BEST THEY CAN
DO IS KEEP THEMSELVES SAFE.
WE KNOW HOW TO PROTECT OURSELVES
FROM THE VIRUS.
NO NOT ONLY JUST THE VACCINE.
HAND WASH, COVER YOUR MOUTH AND
SOCIALLY DISTANCE.
THAT’S WHAT THEY ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO DO.
RACHEL: DOCTOR, HAVE YOU ALWAYS
BEEN GIVING US AMAZING ADVICE
THROUGHOUT THIS PANDEMIC THANKS